عندما يفكر الناس في برلين ، فإنهم
يعتقدون أن شيئًا ما يقفز خفيفًا في الجولات ليس
صعبًا عندما يفكر الناس في
فنون الدفاع عن النفس هو لكمات في الوجه
دم مكسور الأنف ، يصرخون
بالضربة القاضية ، لكن جميع الراقصين
مقاتلون وجميع المقاتلين راقصون
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي جورج مكارثي وأنا  أنا
مدرس ضيف في الاقتراع البريدي ، أنا أيضًا
مقاتل محترف في فنون الدفاع عن النفس ، لقد
كنت راقصًا رئيسيًا في العديد من الشركات
أسافر في جميع أنحاء العالم ، كنت
أقوم بالطيار بشكل احترافي منذ أن أبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا
وبدأت في الرقص لأن الرقص مهم جدًا
في بلدي جورجيا ونحن
جميعًا الراقصين ، تعرضت للتنمر لأنني كنت
راقصة صغيرة كانوا يقولون إنني
أنثوية كنت مهينًا لحماية نفسي من
التعرض للتنمر ، أتعلم فنون الدفاع عن النفس أنا
الحزام الأسود من الدرجة الرابعة في
جيو جيتسو البرازيلية  الحزام الأسود في الجودو وأنا
أحب الدرجة الثالثة في كيوكوشن
كاراتيه يعتقد معظم الناس أن
الراقصين المحترفين
والمقاتلين المحترفين مختلفون تمامًا ولكن هناك
المزيد من أوجه التشابه بين  هم في
الاقتراع وفي فنون الدفاع عن النفس ،
فأنت تريد الحفاظ على توازنك في كل من
تريد أداء الأسلوب بحيث تبدو
جميلة في القصيدة ورائعة في فنون
الدفاع عن النفس التي تدربها كل يوم لجعل
التنفيذ ممتازًا علمني فنون الدفاع عن النفس
كيف أتحكم في نفسي الانضباط
الجيد ولكن  كنت سأجعل فنانًا قتاليًا أفضل
كراقصة ، لا أحد يستطيع أن يخبرني
أنني ضعيف وبصفتي فنانًا عسكريًا ، لا أحد
يستطيع أن يقول لي لا ، أنت فقط تضرب الأشخاص الذين
لا يمكنك الحكم على الأشخاص من خلال المظهر الذي
لا تعرفه أبدًا